- Sam Tessier et sa vingtaine
d'amis du 72e groupe scouts
coincés à l'aéroport de
Vancouver depuis h
SAM TESSIER, 72e groupe scouts
- Avec Air Canada, on nous
a dit : il ne rest
place, pour les hôtels fait
que... un peu entre guillemets,
débrouillez-vous.
- Après 11 heures d'attente
en vue de prendre son vol vers
Whitehor
apprend qu'il est annulé.
Aucun hébergement ni transport
n'ont étsporteur, Air Canada.
Elle et son groupe n'ont pas eu
que de dormir à même
le plancher de l'aéroport.
- C'est même pas tout le monde
ça fait que ça a pris du temps,
mais on s'est trouvé une "gate"s
le fin fond de l'aéroport, puis
on a tout dormi par terre sur le
- Pour l'instant, Air Canada n'a
de 10 $ pour son déjeuner.
- Peut-être qu'on va avoir 10 $
pour dîner et souper, on ne
le sait pas encore.
- Et ce genre de déboires
à l'aéroport, n'épargne
visiblement que très peu
de voyageurs. Le cycliste
peut en témoigner, il a perdu
toute trace de ses bagages
à son arrivée au Danemark,
en vue de sa participation
de voyageurs. Le cycliste
professionnel Guillaume Boivu
toute trace de ses bagages
à son arrivée au
en vue de sa participation
au Tour de France.GUILLAUMGUILLN
cycliste professionnel- Puis, j,
pas de vélos. À mon avis, je
vais l'avoir à la fin du tour,p.
- Eric Kennedy, Caroline
Brunelle et leurs deux enfants
ont pris l'avion pour l'Italie,
le 23 juin. Ils doivent
des milliers de dollars de frais
supplémentaires pour rentrer
à la maison.
- Le vol, le tronçon de Montréal
à St-Jean était ast là
que le problème est parti.
On s'est dit : Ah, ok, de toute
façon, on rentre au pays, on va
être daays, c'est
correct, on peut s'arranger.biei
recommencent à voyager, Sam
spère bientôt voir
la lumière au bout du tunnel.
Ici Gabrielle Proulx, Radio-Can